[Musique]
c'est une journée ordinaire pour harry
hoffman dans quelques heures
cet architecte de formation sera avec
des clients en plein travail
c'est là que nous allons le retrouver un
restaurant chic à l'ambiance tamisée
il est fréquenté par des avocats des
médecins et des architectes comme harry
sauf qu'ici harris et le service
alors comment on avait trouvé les
gnocchis délit vous l'avait dit et le
kram
c'est parfait excellent si harry se
retrouvent ici c'est parce qu'il a
souscrit un prêt pour payer ses études
comme la majorité des jeunes américains
ce prêt il a dû commencer à le
rembourser dès l'obtention de son
diplôme il ya quatre ans seulement
harry n'a pas trouvé tout de suite
d'emploi d'architectes crise économique
oblige pour payer les premières traites
il a dû décrocher un job en urgence us
je m'imaginais passer des journées dans
un beau bureau à dessiner à construire
des bâtiments owens j'ai un peu renoncé
à cette partie de ma vie tête même si
c'est difficile d'avaler la pilule soit
heureux si j'avais été architecte
j'aurais fait la décôte ce restaurant le
cas d' harry n'est pas isolé il vient de
découvrir que son collègue a eu les
mêmes rêves que lui moi aussi j'ai
commencé comme architecte
oui c'est à l'école de ponnat ah ben on
était à pomona c'est une super fuck
heureusement qu'on travaille dans ce
restaurant sinon notre situation serait
bien pire comme harry ils sont chaque
année des millions d'étudiants à
s'endetter quelques années à étudier des
décennies à rembourser et pour certains
au final la précarité parfois même la
pauvreté comme si l'université
américaine pouvait aussi faire dérailler
des vides comment les étudiants font-ils
pour rembourser pourquoi les banques
leurs prêts tels autant d'argent
ces empreintes vont-ils provoquer une
nouvelle bulle financière
nous allons vous emmener dans une
amérique qui voit ses diplômés sombre et
une amérique qui laisse ses banques
tromper sa jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au commencement pour comprendre le
phénomène il faut réaliser une chose
pousser les portes de l'université
américaine
c'est signé un énorme chèque
nous sommes à chicago au salon de
l'étudiant des commerciaux viennent de
tout le pays vente et les programmes de
leur établissement nous proposons des
formations dans le secteur de l'enfance
de la jeunesse et de la santé
nos perspectives d'emploi sont bonnes
avec nous il y a de grandes chances de
faire une bonne carrière
nous accompagnons alexis un jeune
américain préoccupé par son avenir comme
tant d'autres passer du lycée à
l'université est un pari qui engage pour
la vie je m'appelle alexis je suis
intéressé par des études de psychologie
ma question c'est combien de temps il
faut pour aller jusqu'au bout la plupart
de nos cursus dure entre 5 et 7 ans
entre 5 et 7 ans vous coûtera trente
mille dollars par an trente mille
dollars soit plus de 20000 euros pour
devenir psychologue
il faut donc débourser au minimum 100
mille euros aux états unis on investit
dans un diplôme comme on achète une
maison
ce qu'il ya de bien dans notre cursus
c'est qu'il est plutôt bon marché
ça coûte onze mille dollars par semestre
c'est à dire 22 mille dollars par an au
bout des quatre années d'études on doit
s'attendre à quel montant d'endettement
la dette pourrait atteindre 200 mille
dollars à la fin des études
deux cent mille dollars c'est-à-dire
150000 euros pour devenir médecin
en france un étudiant père est cinquante
fois moins dans une université publique
pour ceux comme alexis qui n'ont pas de
fortune familiale emprunter l unique
solution
cette dette s'alourdit au fil du temps
et pour nous les gens des classes
populaires c'est difficile de s'engager
sur des montants pareil
mais rares sont les étudiants prudente
comme alexis la plupart n'imagine pas en
souscrivant leurs emprunts qu'ils
signent une ardoise qui devront régler
parfois toute une vie en californie
harris on aura encore les doigts il se
demande chaque matin s'il parviendra un
jour à se débarrasser de sa dette
une dette colossale deux cent mille
dollars soit 150 mille euros c'est ce
que lui ont coûté ses études
chaque mois la banque lui demande deux
mille dollars soit 1500 euros problème
c'est à peu de choses près son salaire
il ne peut pas tout payer
il ne rembourse que les intérêts c'est
impossible pour moi de rembourser ce
qu'il me demande et en même temps de
payer mon loyer la nourriture qui est si
tu regardes lasser les intérêts suite à
33000 489 dollars je peux t'acheter une
très belle voiture avec ce total ne fait
qu'augmenter
c'est effrayant en principe un prêt
étudiant sert de tremplin pour une vie
meilleure
dont la réalité dari ce serait plutôt un
toboggan vers la précarité
il a misé 150000 euros il ne lui reste
que ces cahiers d'étudiants fait mes
devoirs d'avant mon portfolio de l'école
d'architecturé vous le regardez souvent
non sinon ça me donnera envie de me
replonger
c'est un immeuble d'affaires que j'ai
dessiné pour se débarrasser au plus vite
de son fardeau
harry est prête à tout essayer
bonjour à tous en direct de san diego je
m'appelle harry hoffman je suis
directeur commercial de gobi h2o et je
vais vous parler de notre superbe
bouteille réutilisable du télé achat sur
internet pour une gourde
le diplômé en architecture n'aurais
jamais imaginé en arriver là c'est du
plastique compressé ce qui se fait de
mieux sur le marché aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement solide
c'est inusable vous régler ses dettes
arrivent à devoir un peu patienter vous
gagnez combien avec ce business combien
je gagne pas un kopeck 0 qui je fais
tout ce que je peux pour m'en sortir
pour garder la tête hors de l'eau
j'espère pouvoir rejoindre lille qui est
là-bas au loin là où un jour j'espère
voir mais margarita
mais lille ne se rapprochent jamais n'y
arrive pas
chaque année ils sont des millions de
diplômés à ne pas pouvoir rembourser
leurs traites aucune région n'est
épargnée
comble de l'absurdité certains ont même
accumulé tellement de dette qu'ils ont
été contraints d'abandonner leurs études
nous sommes dans l'état du massachusetts
bienvenue à d'aucune de notes
que puis je faire pour vous
[Musique]
bienvenue à jean donuts que puis-je pas
pour vous aujourd'hui stéphanie maudit
chaque jour qui passe depuis qu'elle a
dû quitter son école d'arts graphiques
six mois avant la fin de ses études sa
banque a brusquement arrêté de lui
prêter de l'argent
ce chiffre sur le chronomètre c'est pour
indiquer à quelle vitesse on travaille
bienvenue à d'un kindle que puis je
faire que vous vous travaillez au bon
rythme là là non on n'est pas assez
rapide il faut être pas combien de
préférence dans les 90 vous avez la
pression
bienvenue à la dengue ne puis-je faire
pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est un travail terriblement répétitif
je déteste ça je voulais travailler dans
la décaler pour des bandes dessinées
batman par exemple ça c'est un bon job
rêvé on en est assez loin aujourd'hui
non ouais j'en suis très loin
là c'est la vie
à 25 ans pour stéphanie c'est double
peine son diplôme elle ne peut pas
trouver du travail dans son domaine et
elle doit rembourser une très lourde
dette
j'ai payé 150 mille dollars pour servir
du café jeu avec ce que je fais
stéphanie a de quoi être amer toute
l'histoire de son naufrage tient dans
une caisse ces lettres que sa banque lui
envoie depuis des années sa banque
s'appelle salim et c'est elle qui prête
à la majorité des étudiants américains 1
2 3 4 5
festi 15 près sur ces deux papiers
sommes qui vont de 2022 mille dollars
je ne sais pas pourquoi ouais j'avais 18
ans je n'y connaissais rien je savais
seulement que c'était le moment d'aller
à l'université
j'étais très naïve mais en même temps
ces gens là n'étaient pas du tout ni
faits ni mes hôtes elle savait ce qu'il
faisait
ah ouais jacobins j'aimerais tellement
me réveiller dans le passé me mettre une
gifle et me dire sois pas stupide d'un
bep pas
ah ouais mais là je me suis endetté pour
le reste de ma vie j bref comment sa
banque at-elle pu autoriser autant de
près pourquoi n'at-elle pas tiré avant
la sonnette d'alarmé
pour répondre à ces questions nous avons
rendez vous avec harrison c'est un
étudiant et un militant anti près il
refuse lui-même d'en souscrire avec lui
nous poussons la porte des agences
bancaires pour voir quelles garanties
sont demandées aux étudiants aux
emprunteurs les employés nous informe
que les souscriptions se font
exclusivement en ligne ou par téléphone
chez harrison nous appelons par internet
salim est la banque de stéphanie nous
allons découvrir que l'employé au bout
du fil n'a qu'un seul objectif vendre
ces prêts sans jamais se soucier de la
solvabilité des étudiants vous êtes en
train de me dire que je peux emprunter
sans limite que ça dépend seulement du
prix de la fac
donc si je veux faire un doctorat ou si
je veux faire une faculté de droit je
peux emprunter deux cent mille dollars
si c'est le tarif même si je ne suis pas
sûr de trouver un emploi plus tard je
suis quand même et lisier pour cet
emprunt
puisque vous êtes encore étudiant c'est
bon j'ai bien vu monsieur oui et vous
avez besoin de mon historique de crédit
de mon niveau de renault n'ont pas
d'historique de crédit pas besoin de
savoir si vous avez un travail ou pas
rien de tout cela ne vous inquiétez pas
harrison n'en revient pas il vient
d'apprendre qu'il peut emprunter jusqu'à
200 mille dollars sur un simple coup de
fil c'est vraiment ne vous inquiétez pas
prenez voici d'argent c'est pas étonnant
si les étudiants se retrouvent endettés
avec des banques qui sont très heureuses
de pouvoir prêter à n'importe qui
harrison serait peut-être encore plus
indigné s'il savait comment la banque
salim est harcèle ses débiteurs
stéphanie on sait quelque chose elle qui
doit vivre en colocation pour payer son
loyer
salim elle lui réclame 1400 euros par
mois elle en gagne 1300 elle a reçu
aujourd'hui une nouvelle lettre de
rappel
ça c'est la méthode douce de ma banque
je m'appelle tout le temps d'un g5 6
appel vendredi 12 mercredi
d'habitude je ne décroche pas lorsque je
veux pas avoir cette conversation à
chaque fois comment allez-vous me
rembourser alors je ne sais pas je ne
voulais pas cet argent est ce que vos
parts on peut lui donner de l'argent
vendez votre voiture mais moi je ne peux
pas faire ça je n'ai besoin pour aller
au travail
c'est très stressant à chaque fois que
j'aurai je pleure beaucoup
hu pourtant à stéphanie fait tout pour
s'en sortir
serveuse le matin dans une cafétéria
serveuse le soir dans une pizzeria
ça vous fera soit son tennis de l'a75
stéphanie doit compter sur ses
pourboires pour assurer son quotidien
laval angers 11 dollars ça va aider à
payer l'essence ses pourboires cette
semaine vont être précieux j'achèterai
ma nourriture avec et tout le reste dont
j'ai besoin à cause de la crise le
restaurant fonctionne au ralenti
stéphanie cherche d'autres emplois elle
a même posté sur internet une annonce de
femme de ménage 153 dollars 10,9 pour
une semaine de travail
je suis sur le point de me déclarer en
faillite personnelle parce que je ne
peux pas rembourser mon prêt étudiant
ça veut dire quoi faillite personnelle
ça veut dire qu'ils peuvent saisir une
partie de mon salaire entre 10 et 35 %
directement deux semaines après notre
tournage
stéphanie n'a pas eu le choix elle a dû
se mettre en faillite personnelle
maintenant que la banque va se servir
directement sur son compte les revenus
de la jeune femme sont dérisoires
les étudiants américains vivent à crédit
leur dette ont atteint un niveau record
l'année dernière
mille milliards de dollars l'équivalent
de la dette publique espagnole
au delà des destins individuels c'est
devenu un enjeu national
le président américain a fini de
rembourser son propre prêt étudiant
il y a seulement huit ans vivre avec ce
type de dette oblige à faire des choix
douloureux au moment de commencer sa vie
d'adulte
ça peut être renoncé à acheter votre
première maison ou alors ça vous pousse
à fonder une famille plus tard ce n'est
pas juste dur pour vous dur pour votre
famille c'est douloureux aussi pour
toute notre économie dans tous les
esprits il y à la crise des emprunts
immobiliers
les fameux subprimes ce c'était il ya
cinq ans les banques avait été accusé
d'avoir prêté sans aucun discernement
une agence fédérale est né l'année
dernière pour les surveiller c'est la
mission d'euros id chopra tous les
dossiers qu'il traite concerne les prêts
étudiants
pour lui le problème est presque réglé
nous avons constaté de fortes
ressemblances entre les pratiques
appliquées sur le marché des subprimes
est celle qui concerne le marché des
prêts étudiants
la cause de cela plus de 858
l'emprunteur se retrouvent en situation
de faillite personnelle
si les banques n'ont pas changé de
pratique c'est qu'il ya une faille dans
le système non eh bien on n'est pas sûr
et en général on reçoit des témoignages
antérieurs à la crise immobilière bien
sûr il ya du nettoyage à faire un essai
aussi de s'assurer à travers nos
interventions que ces mauvaises
pratiques ne se répéteront pas à
l'évidence cette agence fédérale cherche
à minimiser l'ampleur du phénomène
victime des banques les étudiants le
sont aussi parfois de certaines
universités celle qu'on appelle fort
profitent des entreprises privées qui
cherche à dégager un bénéfice maximum
pour rémunérer leurs actionnaires
symbole de cette dérive le west routes
collèges à chicago la justice américaine
l'accuse de marketing mensonger
l'université a pas de ses élèves à coup
de spots publicitaires au collège j'ai
obtenu ma maîtrise en trois ans
seulement et moi aidé à écrire mon cv
quand j'ai reçu mon diplôme j'avais tout
ce qu'il fallait pour commencer ma
carrière
celle qui visionnent cette publicité
accrue aux mirages tamarins a étudié par
internet pendant trois ans au westwood
collège pour décrocher une maîtrise de
communication
ils sont très convaincants ils te
donnent l'impression qu'ils vont
apporter tout ce dont tu as besoin pour
trouver le job de ses rêves
mais si complètement fausse tamara se
plaignait pendant ses études du faible
niveau des cours et du manque de sérieux
des professeurs une fois le diplôme en
poche c'est le coup de grâce c'est ma
maîtrise de communication un bout de
papier qui m'a coûté 50 mille dollars
mais qui ne vaut rien dans mes
entretiens professionnels on m'a
conseillé de retirer ce diplôme de mon
cv
parce qu'il me dessert peut retrouver du
travail elle considère l'enseignement
dispensé à westwood comme une farce
c'était mon rêve américain d'aller à
l'université pour progresser dans la vie
ça eu l'effet opposé d'immenses regrets
et ce sentiment amer d'avoir été
escroqué je vais vous montrer notre
technique qu'ils ont pour gagner de
l'argent
ça ce sont les livres que nous devions
le racheter je dépensais au moins 500 $
par semestre en livre c'est un vrai
souci pour moi je les ai donc contactés
pour savoir si on pouvait les acheter
ailleurs mais on ne nous laissez pas
accéder à nos cours internet si on
n'apportait pas la preuve que nous
avions acheté leurs livres chez eux
donc on avait vraiment pas le choix à
cause des intérêts sa dette s'élève
désormais à 60000 euros
c'est presque deux fois plus qu'au
départ
tamara a peut-être été un peu naïve
c'est en tout cas ce que pense romane
son mari lui a grandi en urss ou
emprunté était impossible
ici les gens se disent allez on va
emprunter ou mettre ça sur la carte de
crédit c'est tellement normal pour les
gens de faire comme ça il devrait
prévoir davantage sur plan financier
parce que prendre après vivre à crédit
c'est pas la bonne solution
c'est du court terme tamara aimerait
bien porter plainte contre son école
mais elle n'a pas les moyens de payer un
avocat
de son côté le procureur de la région a
ouvert une enquête sur les méthodes du
westwood collège depuis cet
établissement s'est il remis en question
c'est ce que nous allons chercher à
savoir avec alexis souvenez vous c'est
cet étudiant qui visitait le salon de
chicago
lui aussi est un ancien du west ou de
collège
[Musique]
que tu leur dis que tout souci c'est le
financement des études il noie le
poisson
l'étudiant se dit ok je vais pas
m'inquiéter pour ça ce sont eux les
experts ils connaissent leur travail
c'est comme ça que ça se passe tu vas
voir
là c'est l'immeuble du web du collège le
west routes collèges a refusé toutes nos
demandes d'interview
alexis va se faire passer pour un
étudiant sur un campus de l'école où il
n'est pas connu
nous allons filmer son entretien en
caméra cachée pour moi le plus important
c'est comment payer mes études
cool on va voir ça mais d'abord on voit
si vous avez choisi la bonne filière ok
moi mon souci c'est l'argent comment je
paye bien sûr comment ça marche comme on
paye vous êtes un étudiant comme les
autres vous n'avez pas les poches
pleines
mais faites moi confiance on a des
femmes seules au chômage avec deux
enfants qui viennent ici donc faites moi
confiance
alexis a passé pour la deuxième fois cet
entretien
pour lui rien n'a changé ce sont
toujours les mêmes mensonges l'éducation
pour eux c'est juste une marchandise un
produit qu'il vend aux étudiants ils
s'en foutent de l'éducation ou des
étudiants
ils veulent simplement profiter de ces
jeunes qui essaye de se construire un
avenir et rien d'autre dans toutes ces
écoles les mêmes techniques bien rodées
qui selon certains s'apparentent à du
cynisme on leur vend de l'espoir de la
prospérité
quand tu parles aux étudiants donnent
leur ce qu'ils veulent les gars soyons
leur drogue enfoncé la seringue
rendez les dépens d'un fait les signer
et la journée finie pour vous rentrez
dans votre famille le monde est beau
c'est merveilleux tout ce cajon décrit
dans son one man show c'est du vécu
avant d'être comédien il travaillait
pour une école fort profite où il en
relais des centaines d'étudiants
on avait chaque mois des quotas plutôt
élevé d'étudiants a enrôlé équipe pour
garder ton emploi tu pouvais être aviez
à faire signer une personne qui n'aurait
pas dû être acceptée sinon tu pouvais
perdre son boulot je me souviens d'un
candidat qui savait à peine lire
alors je m'en suis aperçu quand je lui
ai demandé de lire la fiche
d'inscription il n'y arrivait pas just
friends est la bonne chose à faire ce
que je voulais faire c'était de le
renvoyer en disant bon écoute je vais te
conseiller d'autres pistes on m'a
demandé d'aller au bout et de l'inscrire
ironie du sort si aaron n'a pas
démissionné plus tôt c'était pour
rembourser son propre prêt étudiant
l'établissement où a travaillé aaron se
situe dans un quartier pauvre ces écoles
fort profite prospère dans ces banlieues
déshéritées depuis une vingtaine
d'années autrefois marginal elle attire
aujourd'hui un étudiant américain sur
dix voilà devant nous c'est là où j'ai
travaillé
c't'une ces étudiants ce sont des cibles
faciles quand tu viens d'une famille
pauvre tu as envie de monter dans la
société de grimper sur l'échelle sociale
ces étudiants avaient tellement envie de
changer de vie se former c'est de gagner
de l'argent
il avait tellement envie d'avoir leur
part du rêve américain kool keith des
universités privées qui ciblent des
étudiants modestes et les appauvrissent
davantage des facultés public qui voient
leurs moyens fondre le tableau est bien
sombre
bonjour vous êtes avec richard wolf en
direct de new york
les budgets des écoles publiques sont en
train d'être réduit
c'est la conséquence directe de la crise
économique cet économiste new yorkais
est en colère pour lui la crise de la
dette étudiante menace de se propager
dans toute la société ou presque cette
crise détruit la masse de la classe
moyenne celle qui va à l'université pour
être éduqué et formé et trouver un
travail
grâce à cette formation le pays va se
retrouver avec un petit nombre de gens
qui seront formés dans des universités
prestigieuses
ils dirigeront les grandes entreprises
et tous les autres retourneront aux
années 60 où il n'existait pas de
formation supérieure pour tous
est il encore possible d'étudier en
échappant au surendettement
laura et auch et ont trouvé chacun leur
solution aussi radicale l'une que
l'autre
auch et à 21 ans son choix nous allons
voir qui le paye au prix fort
il est étudiant en art dramatique à la
faculté de santa monica
ils refusent d'emprunter de l'argent et
pourtant il est sans ressources
il vient même de perdre sa bourse
d'études faut de bons résultats c'est ce
qu'il explique aujourd'hui à la
caissière du bureau des étudiants il
faut que tu aies de meilleures notes que
tu fasses un bon semestre et tu
récupères rata bourse
je l'espère son bourses d'études sont
prêts bancaires
auch et pourrait chercher un job mais il
veut se consacrer à plein temps à ses
études
laura elle a emprunté mais elle a trouvé
une astuce pour sortir plus vite de
l'endettement
[Musique]
nous sommes au kansas elle est arrivée
de sa ville du new hampshire et effacer
la moitié de son ardoise ici c'est
incroyablement plat tellement plaques
tu peux voir jusqu'à l'horizon et comme
tu peux le constater il ya presque pas
d'arbres j'ai pour faire nos courses on
est obligé de faire une heure de route
le kansas frappé par la désertification
a offert à l'aura de rembourser 15 mille
dollars de son prêt étudiant
une seule condition que cette
institutrice s'installe avec jared son
mari ici pendant au moins cinq ans à la
ville le rat vivait avec ses parents à 4
dans un appartement pour économiser et
rembourser son prêt les deux époux
habite maintenant seul dans une grande
maison
c'est super nous avons notre salon une
cuisine grande cuisine j'adore
maintenant j'ai ma propre cuisine à moi
là c'est notre chambre
avant on n'avait même pas de placard à
nous pour ranger nos vêtements sales et
les mettre sur des cintres qu'on
suspende est comme on pouvait
laura enseigne désormais à plein temps
dans une petite classe de cp
quant à jared son mari il a trouvé dans
le kansas le poste de travail qu'ils
recherchaient depuis des mois il est
pasteur dans une église un néorural lui
aussi avant quand on voulait sortir
dîner on avait quand même plus de choix
oui il y avait plein de fast food de
restaurants le problème c'est surtout le
café ya pas de bon café ici
y a pas grave
grâce à cette aide du kansas laura est
rassuré elle songe à fonder une famille
mais elle refuse de s'emballer
chaque mois ses 500 dollars de traites
étudiante continuent de tomber
j'ai un rappel de versements affaire
réglée maintenant ne l'oublierons pas
comme nous avons emménagé ici il était
déjà là il y avait un courrier 2 qui
nous attendait dans la boîte aux lettres
dans cinq ans si tout se passe bien
l'institutrice aura entièrement
remboursé son prêt étudiant
à 32 ans il pourra réaliser son rêve
américain
de nombreux enfants dans une grande
maison mais la solution proposée par le
kansas a ses limites
l'université américaine peut-elle avoir
pour vocation de repeupler le désert